[Music]
of Goble of the
tongs Heritage Turkeys they are truly a
natural sustainable
animal the term Heritage has only been
around about 12
years a Heritage turkey is what we used
to call Standard bread sort of
equivalent to saying pure bread the meat
is much darker and that's the direct
results of physical activity The Wider
the meat the poorer the
[Music]
nutrition if you were to compare a
Heritage turkey with the industrial
commercial white turkey the 99.99 % of
all the turkeys being produced they now
can get a 20 lb turkey in 12
weeks my turkeys get to Market weight
takes 28 to 30 weeks the metabolic rate
hasn't been changed or mutated the other
thing is it can still naturally made the
modern industrial turkey can no longer
naturally made on its own they get so
morbidly obese so quickly they're
incapable of performing an actual Act of
breeding
none of my turkeys are ever confined
even my breeder turkeys are out in
pastures I probably spend 90% of my time
either cleaning Waters watering or
hauling feed right now what they're
being fed is an all vegetarian diet we
do not feed antibiotics we don't feed
gross
[Music]
stimulants
when people buy one of my turkeys I say
just put it in the pan a little salt and
water and roast it and taste turkey for
the first time tastes great tastes like
turkey